welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about that angry
green monster that's living inside of
all of us and what it will take to
finally kill them
hopefully with not a lot of violence
because you know when you turn into a
green rage monsters it's not very good
my name is mt and i'm here today with
offspring producer brandon who was
pretty much on screen producer brandon
at this point what's going on brandon
you can't change my title it's too much
paperwork just leave it the way it is
it's true we can't pay you if we change
your password so it's so hard to get the
government to change your name it's very
complicated empty
i have to stay this way forever it's
true off-screen producer brandon brandon
is his last name off-screen is his first
name it's a family name last name
off-screen
[Music]
no that sounds awkward cut that out
i feel bad for every every immigrant who
felt the need to change their name to
live in this country it's not fair i'm
so sorry i apologize from a place of
privilege i apologize
yay
all right hit me with that big question
brandon oh mt have i got a big question
for you okay uh and it has to do with
that chunky uh post-credits scene so if
for some reason you haven't seen the
movie yet i guess this is a spoiler
warning but frankly we shouldn't have to
do that anymore you should have seen the
movie by now yes seriously if you
haven't seen shogi yet stop what you're
doing go see that magnificent movie and
then come back here because go see the
movie i mean maybe you were a baby who
was just born yesterday and if so
welcome to the world it's in bad shape
right now uh right but also marvel puts
scenes at the end of the movie so stay
for the very end of the credits okay
so in that first post-credit scene we
saw i guess we'll call it a mid-credits
scene empty okay uh we see a hologram of
our boy bruce banner he's back he's
alive he's there in hologram form uh but
it wasn't smart hulk like we last left
him right we just see him as just bruce
he's 100 bruce um so that leads us to
this week's big question
how did hulk transition back into banner
this is a great question that had us all
scratching our heads when we all left
the theater and just to catch everyone
up when we last saw hulk in the mcu he
had been the smart hulk or professor
hulk form for the entire run of avengers
end game and our last look at him was
when he sent steve rogers back through
time to replace all of those infinity
stones and create a new branch timeline
with peggy that i'm sure caused a few
raised eyebrows at the tva but you know
eyebrows of
what's going on there but we get it oh
yeah yeah you know they were watching
they saw the little spike and they're
like what's happening here let's check
this oh oh hello
yeah let it go
awesome okay this is a hot timeline
i like to think that tva has like a
virginity clause it's like let him be
sudden let's let him let him go he's
losing the v card
that timeline mt are you trying to say
my boy steve rogers was a virgin no way
that dude i mean that dude smashed okay
he was a nice gay man he was polite but
he smashed he smashed a ton he probably
smacked i mean he was a very attractive
guy but he was also
stuck on peggy i don't know i think he
was just saving himself for for that
good uh
good british stuff i refuse to believe
that 100 empty i'll derail this entire
big question i will not have
my boy steve rogers bad mouth like this
okay he may have kept that card for a
long time
but it got turned in well before he
branched the timelines
well before all right we should do a
whole big question
don't get me started don't get me
started i'll bring the receipts him in
that basically took a shower together uh
er was it civil war or winter soldier a
winter soldier
winter soldier one of them they took a
shower together winter soldier stephen
that the most sexual tension i've ever
seen in any marvel movie
it was just here here
good god i'm still sweating to this day
every time i sweat on a big question
it's because i'm sweating about that
scene in winter soldier
but bruce was still smart hulk instilled
in his arm sling thanks to the massive
damage caused by the use of the nano
infinity gauntlet to bring back half of
the life in the universe and this
lasting damage is in itself a huge deal
for hulk in the mcu because hulk in the
comics is famously undamageable like he
is the most like the resilient man in
the world like we've seen him burnt down
to a skeleton eaten alive by bugs been
completely dismembered and every time he
heals back up like it often in a matter
of minutes because like you just he just
can't die well he just like in the
comics you're right empty he gets like
stronger the more you hurt him the
stronger he gets i mean i know he didn't
start out that way like old old hulk
yeah there was some like damage you
could do to him but like modern hulk
ever since like the late 70s early 80s
it's basically indestructible you know
he's like wolverine where like you just
can't you can't put him down he's
yeah impossible to kill but yeah even
joe russo one of the directors for
avengers end game has confirmed that
this damage to hulk is permanent because
in an interview with comicbook.com joe
said about the damage to hulk's arm it's
permanent damage the same way that it
was permanent damage with thanos and
it's irreversible damage so like that's
kind of crazy like that is
i mean which it makes sense considering
like you know thanos was also pretty
messed up after his snap yeah we saw the
damage that it did to thanos and he was
like still injured when they chopped off
his head just a simple man living on a
farm yeah he was he was damaged up he
was he's an eternal with a deviant gene
you know like he's he's maybe stronger
than the hulk and he was damaged so it
was crazy to see that damage is like
kind of permanent for the hulk and yeah
it's a big deal big deal yeah like it is
really cool that the mcu made that
decision it's like hey hulk is
permanently damaged and i wonder exactly
how the hulk is taking that himself
because like he's never been damaged in
his entire life this is his first
boo-boo his first major
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine but you just can't get into
it because they would never understand
but yeah the russo brothers have also
said that coming up against the full
power of the infinity stones does a
reputable damage to your body so the
fact that we see bruce in bruce form in
the shanghai post credit scene and he's
still in that sling shows us that the
damage taken by smart hulk in endgame is
a permanent part of bruce now and maybe
it plays into the transformation back
into bruce so let's go into some of the
ways that this transition back into
bruce may have happened but yeah let us
remind ourselves how he became smart
hulk in the first place because when we
first met smart hulk at the diner in
avengers end game he describes how he
was able to mix the brains with the
brawn by spending 18 months in the gamma
lab which kind of sounds like he was
making a rap album but you know whatever
um
down in the game of lab i got no snare
in my headphones turn it up baby turn up
this is bruce bruce
working on it it's working on it for a
very long time even though uh dr dre is
never coming out with that album uh
sorry sorry don't mean to on you
but it's not happening put them in the
game seriously 18 months of the game but
we won't get that album you're gonna
have that album for sure
for sure then bruce started looking at
the hulk as the cure instead of a
disease that he had to deal with and it
was also clever of the filmmakers to set
up smart hulk like this because we
needed a hulk that was strong enough to
take the immense blast of energy that
wielding the infinity stones would
create but also smart enough to know
what to do with them because
i would be very terrified if we had just
regular hulk snapping he's a good god
wow uh it would be it's really terrible
but that would be a really great what if
episode like what if the hulk got his
wish i would really love to see what
would happen if hulk got a wish in the
snap and i honestly think that he may
have but anyway we'll get to that we'll
get to that we'll get to that we'll get
to that but it also obviously enabled
him to be the hulk during the time heist
while maintaining his wit so how exactly
did he undo this murder like was this
something that bruce wanted to do or is
this just a refresh of the character by
the filmmakers so let's pitch some
theories it is crazy mt because you're
right like the the filmmakers did a
great job
every time they have to have hulk in a
film it's like how do we do this is he
like
unstable does he have some agency and
he's like slowly evolved all the way to
smart hulk and it does seem like they're
trying to reset in a way right yeah
because
we can't go back to just having like
unhinged bulk again or maybe we can i
don't know
but uh i think they took it as far as
they were gonna go and they're like we
can't just leave them smart hulk forever
now i think i liked you better either of
the other ways so we're gonna have to
find a new problem for old brucy to deal
with oh yeah because like it's it's sort
of like the same thing with spider-man's
curse about like him constantly being
unlucky the main draw about the hulk is
that his struggle with bruce banner like
him and bruce banner struggle for like
dominance and like they're just struggle
with getting along with each other so
like yeah that status quo was never
going to never be that way
smart hulk was never going to be the the
last step for hulk yeah but one way
bruce may have reverted is through some
quantum de-aging technology and eric
actually brought up this idea in a
previous video about wong and
abomination's appearance in shanghai an
endgame when we first see smart hulk
messing with pym's quantum tunnel as he
tries to figure out time travel he
accidentally de-ages scott by pushing
time through him
it's baby it's scott as a baby he'll
grow and bruce may have continued to use
the same tech to try to undo the smart
hulk he had created by using quantum
time fluctuations to revert himself back
to human form and this could explain
abomination's new enhanced appearance in
chongqi if smart hulk had tested his
quantum aging theory on abomination it
might have altered abomination's
appearance okay makes sense that makes
sense um it's also possible that smart
hulk figured out a way to get back to
bruce while working on abomination in
another sense because abomination is
unable to revert back to human form so
it's possible that bruce banner was
experimenting with a way to get
abomination back to blonsky and also
found a new way to transform for himself
that's an interesting idea yeah it is
that is one way to think of it like
using the quantum technology to revert
back to another form it was i mean it's
hard to tell in shanghai it happened so
fast he's a hologram he kind of looks
old i think bruce looks like a little
old but obviously yeah the actor mark
ruffalo is like aging too so like that
they'll always be fighting that even
though maybe just insult mark ruffalo
sorry michael you're growing up you're
growing up uh sorry i had to break it to
you marvel has an incredible de-aging
technology we'll never know how old
anybody is in the marvel universe but
but i mean
you have to imagine like if he didn't
want to if he was trying to get back to
bruce
from smart hulk and like was unable to
just do it on his own that makes me
wonder if like the smart hulk we saw was
really a blending of the two or if hulk
was in more control it was like no you
don't get to go back we're gonna i'll
let you be smarty boy pants in this body
but we get to stay green the whole time
and maybe like in a way bruce was
trapped there for a little while and had
like stockholm syndrome where he was
like no this is great i like this i like
being smart hulk but really he's like
i'm sick of eating all these eggs uh i
broke all my toilets
what am i gonna do i got this used bed
what do i need to get back i can't find
an apartment in the city that's big
enough for me like right oh my i feel
like being smart hulk is more of an
inconvenience than me yeah he can't go
to the movies he can't go to the grocery
store like everyone knows who he is no
one knows what bruce banner looks like
no one gives a what he looks like
like he could just talk
i like this idea that either by hook or
by crook bruce found a way to get out
while while experimenting on abomination
that's like a whole other thing i mean
it's hard to imagine that bruce isn't
aware that abomination is out there
somewhere if wong's working with him i
don't know how close bruce and wong are
you know someone's
there's a lot of secrets going on right
now
secret invasion maybe
no i i like that you brought up first of
all those two points first of all with
secret invasion what if smart hulk
revert back to bruce foreign because
like there's this weird like racism with
green stuff oh he's a pretty secret
invasion yeah i was like you know what
i'd rather not be putting on green face
during this racially tense time
and also you have to think about how
blonsky you know is this monster right
that sort of has this like sickness
affliction that was given to him by the
government so like the government would
want to revert him back to blonsky form
a to cover up their tracks but also
because blonsky is a threat like
containing this huge raging monster
wastes a lot of money but also you know
you kind of risk the fact that like you
kind of risk the chance of him just
busting out and like hurting people in
the process so like they want to undo it
so but like abomination was never
like as
i don't want to say mindless to the hulk
but he was in more
emil had more agency over abomination
than like hulk and bruce who are kind of
fighting each other because like
abomination was able to talk normal talk
that sounds awful abomination was able
to talk like emile and kind of you know
do his thing so
yeah it doesn't make sense what you're
saying mt that like the government would
want to find a way to get him back
because for the same reason they if they
want to make these super soldiers which
is always the goal of the government uh
they want to be able to turn back to
human form because again they don't want
to buy extra large toilets at the
barracks they don't want to buy extra
large beds at the barracks so they're
like you go be monsters on the
battlefield and when you're back at home
you're a normal sized dude who eats a
normal size amount of eggs okay that's
all we can afford in the military
exactly but it's also possible that
bruce turned to the mystic arts to find
a way back to his human form because we
know that eldritch's magic can be used
to separate a soul from the body even
when it's the hulk and we saw this
moment in end game when the ancient one
soul punch smart hulk and we're going to
dive more into this moment in our bite
size questions later on the show so
please stay tuned for that we know from
the spider-man norway home trailer that
doctor strange is currently in a mood to
up the status quo because that's
what he does that arrogant son of a
so maybe he did some crazy magic
on the smart hulk too and perhaps there
is a soulless hulk body on ice somewhere
ready to be re-emerged with bruce when
the time come and if you think this
theory sounds totally crazy there have
been moments in the comics where bruce
and hulk were separated and more
recently dr doom cut out bruce from the
hulk's brain with an adamantium chainsaw
which is the name of my new band by the
way
chainsaw
new album dropping soon
[Music]
and implanted bruce into a clone body
which is really nuts the comic books get
really crazy um another time bruce was
separated from hulk and became gray hulk
and then regular green hulk went on a
crazy destruction spree since he no
longer had his calming wiser bruce
influence like you mentioned before
did you mention that before it wasn't on
tape
okay whoops uh you just cut out like we
mentioned before but the point is
separating hulk and banner is never
really a good idea medallion says that's
dumb so i'm not going to do that if
that's what they've done here
it's probably not going to end well no
you can't you can't separate them you
need no because yeah bruce banner's like
the governor for uh hulk like keeps them
from going over the speed limit
sometimes you know it's like exactly you
need both forces together uh but the
idea that like yeah somehow dr strange
like separated the two would be crazy
just to see like kind of a lifeless hulk
like just waiting to get its soul back
or something it it it i feel like a a
separation of bruce and hulk is
inevitable this is probably how we can
get ourselves a world war hulk scenario
because world war hulk is a huge big
event in the comics right and i've been
waiting for world war for a long time so
i would love to see
bruce have to go against a team of like
just bru just huge hulk-like beings yeah
um to fight in this world like
everyone's trying to fight the hulk
because the hulk is just tired of i
don't know being disrespected by the
world i think that'd be really fun yeah
i mean ragnarok showed us that hulk
could be driving the car for a while
without any of bruce's like input it
seemed to do okay uh worked his way up
at his job you know was employee of the
month all that stuff uh so it is
possible to have like a fully separated
hulk but and again we're getting this
the bite size uh you got to have bruce
in there still bruce is still the soul
of the soul of hulk so
having them completely separated would
be really interesting because in theory
it's just it would be just the pure rage
uh and anger of bruce inside of the body
of the hulk if the rest of bruce was
gone and that would be so dangerous so
incredibly dangerous but this doctor
strange might do it because this guy's
he's out of control someone's got to
stop him here's a question brandon that
something just popped into my mind while
you were talking just then let's hear
what if because like now that we're
getting into this weird like you know
interdimensional like squid monster
dweller and darkness type deal what if
like in a scenario where like you know
the in a scenario where bruce is no
longer occupying the hulk's body what if
like an interdimensional being were to
occupy the oh my gosh that'd be almost
best real estate in the world
it's free real estate that's a good
point i mean there's a great point uh
empty like what if like a fearlord just
jumps into
uh an empty hulk's husk and now it's
like nightmare driving around or the
dweller underground
or something oh my gosh
keep bruce inside of hulk don't take him
out seriously he's keeping the world
safe he's regulating the world yeah but
brandon is it possible that the hulk is
scared again and hiding away inside of
banner because we know that when he took
a beating from thanos it really shook
the hulk's confidence because he's never
been disrespected like that in his
entire life he's never
ever
like even knight is like when he fought
abomination he took down abomination at
the end so he's literally never in like
all of four ragnarok he's been number
one could it be possible that the angry
green monster inside a banner is scared
again could the permanent damage from
the infinity stones have shook the
hulk's confidence to the point that he's
given up again i think it's a
possibility for sure i mean that would
that would it could happen again i mean
i know they've already told that story
in a way uh but they could happen again
and this time if bruce doesn't want to
tell people he could just be like oh i
figured it out and
i've switched back for a little bit but
it's possible that maybe in this time of
relative peace in the world we don't
really know what's going on in the
expanded world post split right besides
the little little nuggets we've gotten
you know if the hulk is scared again is
like dude my arm's still messed up i
can't be the hulk right now i just need
to rest i need to search inside myself
like find a new path and he's like
hiding again and now bruce is maybe
embarrassed and is like i'm not gonna
tell people that this happened again i
can't tell him again
so he's just like oh i figured it out
don't worry about it it's fine i think
that's a strong possibility it's like i
don't have uh hulk erectile dysfunction
at all
i can i can hulk out whenever i want i
just i have a headache right now and i
don't want to hold on i got my green to
you ready yeah i don't know
don't worry
[Laughter]
it's not right now i'm not feeling it
right now i don't have to be hulk
whenever you want me to be hulk it
doesn't work like that
but no you bring up a really good point
here because like i feel like a lot of
people don't consider the hulk's
emotions too because the hulk is his own
being like that there are two beings
inside of one occupying one physical
space so like the hulk could not only be
scared but could also not want to feel
vulnerable because like again he's never
lost before right has never experienced
a loss and like he's he doesn't want to
be walking around with a sling on his
arm like oh man i only got one arm like
he always wants to be the strongest
person around but also we also have to
consider that hulk loved natasha so much
and he lost he wasn't strong enough to
defeat thanos to keep natasha alive
that's a really great point i just feel
like he's there could be just a whole
emotional aspect and like hulk uh
i don't think he qualifies for therapy i
feel like a lot of therapists would be
scared to uh to to have hulk as a
patient so he's probably just doing his
own thing figuring it out as his own i
mean iron man iron man 3 showed us that
he is usually the therapist oh this is
true therapy even though he's not that
type of guy
but we should also consider the
possibility that the gamma radiation
from the infinity stones are having some
long-term effects on the hull because we
already know that bruce's ability to
absorb the gamma radiation is what led
him to become the hulk in the first
place and that the infinity stones give
off a huge amount of gamma radiation
especially while in use but is it
possible that the game of radiation
absorbed by smart hull during the snap
was able to undo the hull it is it
possible that it slowly killed off
though could the incredible hulk be dead
brandon would that be the case
that's tragic tragic i mean
there's
zero percent chance that kevin feige
would allow one of the better characters
uh of the mcu to get killed off
completely right or universal for that
matter yeah yeah uh
universal's got a they got a whole
roller coaster to talk about um right
uh but yeah
i i do like this idea though that like
there's this long
lasting effect of the infinity stones
that they could have never predicted and
because there was all that gamma
radiation it like kind of undoes the in
intertwining of hulk and banner like
that would be kind of crazy i like that
i don't like to think that hulk's dead
and i don't think he's all the way dead
i know they got she coming but they're
not gonna kill off hulk not like that
not just like in the background
i definitely think that the gamma
radiation had some type of like really
bad or like some type of drastic effect
yeah on the biology of the incredible
hulk and like that like he could be
experiencing those effects and like
really like maybe the opposite could be
happening like what if like every time
bruce hulk's out he's just like just out
of his mind like i'm i've lost control
like i cannot control the whole and like
hulk is even worse than he's ever been
yeah it causes like a uh a chain
reaction of like oh there's too much
game right now
yeah
okay and like maybe maybe even hulk is
scared of that type of hulk he's like
man i like i can't agree yeah yeah like
i don't know what's going on but i'm
getting too angry like i'm scared
he can like only be a hulk like three
more times and then he's dead
that's heavy mt mj you were telling me
about uh as we're talking about like the
infinity stones and stuff you were
telling me about what if the hulk got a
wish
during the stamp
bruce's wish came to fruition with
everyone coming back to the uh to the
universe but i feel like because these
are two souls occupy one space hulk
probably got a wish as well that we
haven't seen play out and maybe this
could be the a little bit of that
playing out because hulk's biggest wish
and biggest goal in life is to be alone
like especially in the comics like he
just doesn't like dealing with people he
just wants to be on his own either he
wants to be alone or he wants to be
loved by people if he has to be around
other people there is a possibility that
after bruce snapped an end game that
like yeah we did see him in his hulk
form but like this could have been
residual of him like slowly powering
down and the hulk completely having left
his being completely so like after that
final end game fight could have been the
last time bruce hulked out because the
hulk is no longer part of him and the in
the snap made hulk his own individual
person on some other planet somewhere
like which continue a world war hulk
scenario okay hulk comes back and he's
like oh now i'm my own person and
everybody on earth um
hated me so i'm gonna like have my
revenge with me i got my buddies here
and we're gonna you up and it's
good
because i want to see that movie i
really want to see your world you want
to say pissed off hulk back for revenge
maybe
because a lot of people i mean like this
is not me complaining but a lot of
people really didn't like the fact that
hulk got beat up by thanos in infinity
war so easily and they're waiting for
hulk to to really just be beefed up or
as beefed up as he was um around that
incredible hulk 2008 period yeah i get
that people are always like that but you
know the comic books are different than
the movies and the movies have to have
like a different narrative structure and
you know a lot of the complaints people
love at
the dc eu is that all these characters
are too powerful and they they don't
have like real emotions or weaknesses
and it's like well hello darkness my old
friend
you know that could be a problem
sometimes so it is good to have a
character even your strongest character
be able to get beat up every now and
then give him a little humility for sure
i feel like with the more powerful
characters in any superhero universe i
feel like that's actually more harder
for for storytellers because like these
characters can literally do anything
like i would hate to have a superman and
like have to like write like why didn't
superman like solve this issue why
didn't the flash like run fast enough to
solve this issue it's like you kind of
have to like give these powerful people
like depower them a little bit or you
you give them the old captain marvel and
be like you don't introduce him until
the last second and then seriously it's
like i'm busy doing other
it's like oh yeah bruce wasn't around
because he was hanging out with betty
for a little bit yeah they were uh bring
back betty seriously i miss betty so
much i love tyler as betty she's
um finally in this brave new multiversal
world of the mcu we cannot immediately
dismiss the fact that the bruce that we
saw in the shanghai post credits is a
variant from another timeline or
universe and one where bruce still has
some lasting arm damage but is able to
transition out of the hulk form highly
unlikely that that is the case here but
it is still possible with this new
multiversal world that we are in yeah i
guess that's possible it could be like a
variant you're right we can't just
possible anything's possible with
infinite universes
and a watcher always watching but uh you
know i don't i don't think that's the
case yeah i agree with you yeah it would
be really weird for like to put a
variant bruce in a post-credits scene
when like probably not everyone has seen
loki yeah but it is a possibility i mean
they technically they put a scroll nick
fury in a whole spider-man film so yeah
i won't put it possible
i won't put it past it this is true
facts
well those are just some of the ways
hulk may have found his way back to
banner oh sorry i i thought of that like
i was picturing like like literally like
like a romance movie i mean it's kind of
ran back to you back to banner maybe
and we better see that mean green
machine on screen again soon because i
miss just regular hulk i just like i
like dumb hulk because it makes me feel
better about my intelligence you bad
friend what's your top pick mt for like
how he did it i'll tell you mine i think
i think
there is something to
hulk exper
bruce smart hulk experimenting on
blonsky and figuring something out for
himself i think that that would be the
most interesting because i would love to
see them interact again but not as foes
as almost like i'm trying to help you
buddy let's not destroy harlem again i
do like that a lot because like that is
very much in line with bruce's character
but i also like the idea that the snap
really messed up bruce and and hulk in
the sense that the hulk is now
transforming in a really weird and scary
way and that like bruce's anger
is now more of like a a real trigger
because like at the beginning of
avengers 1 he's like i'm always angry so
i can just control this but like i want
to see
the struggle of like him like having to
contain his anger more because the snap
like is like all right if you're even a
little bit angry he's coming out and
he's gonna really mess things up i like
something i like that a lot mt
especially because as we move into this
next phase and they're setting up a new
big bad and like kang and all that i
would love that they still have to deal
with the after effects of the snap and
the blip
it's still affecting them even though
it's like we got to move on to other
stuff and it's like no this is still
having drastic effects on everyday life
here like it it just adds more problems
rather than solving a problem new
problem solving a problem new problem
and it would be very much in line with
mordo in the whole like bill comes due
type of mechanicality because
this was a we brought back half of the
universe there has to be a price to be
paid and i think that price is going to
be through uh the hulk so we'll see i
love it we'll see what happens
i love you brandon that's what i love i
love it
well that is it for our first question
in our big question episode but before
we continue our merch partners at epic
hero shop have some really cool stuff
and there's a limited supply of it
available all the other hypn nerds
looking for cool shirts hoodies hats and
stickers are snapping up the merch
inspired by chongqi marvel's what if
loki and spider-man no way home and
depending on when you see this there
also might be some really cool new venom
inspired merch in the shop so grabbing
something from new rockstarsmerch.com is
an awesome way to support this channel
and to show the world your love for your
favorite fandom and before we dive into
our bite size questions next some words
from the people that help us bring big
question to you people like imperfect
foods and you don't need to always be
perfect and neither does your food and
that's where imperfect foods comes in
and perfect foods is a delicious and
sustainable grocery delivery service and
embrace imperfection and get your
groceries delivered weekly with
imperfect foods then all you have to do
is sign up personalize your weekly order
and then shop online each week and get
some sustainable groceries that help you
invest in a better food system all
delivered right to your front door 35 of
the food supply goes unsold or uneaten
and imperfect foods is working to turn
this around by sourcing foods that would
otherwise fall through the cracks with
imperfect you can return your packaging
to them after every order and their
unique delivery model produces 25 to 75
fewer emissions than individual trips to
the grocery store and right now the
perfect foods is offering our listeners
20 off your first four orders when you
go to imperfectfoods.com
and make sure to use the promo code big
question again 20 off your first four
orders and that's up to an 80 value at
imperfectfoods.com using promo code big
questions so try imperfect foods now and
for a limited time get 20 off your first
four orders on your first order go to
imperfectfoods.com use big question sign
up folks everyone is streaming these
days i mean even my meemaw is out there
on twitch no scoping you you guys in
fortnite just totally decimating you i
got no school by his memo the other day
it's no she's no joke
she's a killer she's a straight killer
but whether you're out there and you're
you're already streaming and podcasting
or maybe you're just getting started or
you just want to game with your friends
and have like crystal clear
uh mic audio
you got to have the best folks you need
the best you need the torch mic by
rocket oh the torch is absolutely
jam-packed with pro features like a dual
condenser 24-bit audio quality and up to
48 kilohertz sampling all of that
technical mumbo jumbo that i don't
understand adds up to awesome sound
quality okay it also gives you really
cool features like gesture activated
mute you just kind of whoop and you can
mute it and whoop unmute it that's a lot
of fun tony stark technology
and it also allows you to adjust your
settings without affecting your stream
or installing any drivers or any of that
nonsense plus it looks really great with
some swanky reactive lighting that
reacts to what you do it reacts to how
you game it'll look great on camera my
mimo needs this for her followers they
would love it seriously
but she's telling me to get good it's
going to be in a crystal quality audio
yeah when she's just like she's a
sniping mt from across the map you know
she's going to do a crystal clear audio
uh you know we've used the torch mic
here at new rockstars and we love it
it's great the controls are super
accessible and it makes it really easy
to adjust things on the fly
and it sounds great so grab yourself a
torch mic today because you're also
grabbing professional quality sound just
click the link below in the description
and check it out for yourself torch it
up torch it play my own well now it is
time for our bite size questions brandon
are you ready for our first bite size
question oh i'm ready for them teeny
tiny bites ask questions
all right brandon when the ancient one
pushed banner's astral form from his
professor hulk body we never saw hulk's
astral form does hulk not even have one
and this is from a crack jackal on
discord thank you crack jackal yes thank
you crack jackal this is a hot topic of
debate this gets brought up every now
and then about that scene and end game
uh let's just wrote you know we've
talked about a hulk today so let's just
remind everybody at that point in end
game when the ancient one does the old
astral soul punch move on on hulk we
just see the soul of bruce flow out of
the big green beast okay we see a hulk's
soul we see a bruce soul now you can say
we only see bruce because at this point
bruce and hulk have merged to live in
harmony as smart hulk or professor hulk
whatever you want to call them uh so
we're just seeing the combined soul of
both bruce and hulk manifested as just
bruce but there's a little i think
there's a little more to it than that uh
okay okay hulk isn't an entirely new
being living within bruce okay but he's
rather he's like a gamma-powered
manifestation of an element of bruce's
personality uh bruce bruce doesn't have
multiple souls within his body but
rather has multiple personalities um
okay we can look at the the comics for
further exploration into this uh concept
with bruce banner in incredible hulk
number 227 from 1978 it's established
that hulk is not a mutation of banner's
brain or a separate entity inside of
banner but rather a manifestation of his
childhood rage and anger because his
father was a little abusive no good he's
a piece of
daddy banner
so so at this point daddy banner you're
gonna you're gonna get beat so at this
point in the comics and in society
bruce is
said to have multiple personality
disorder and hulk is
the part of his personality that's like
a very angry personality it was already
there and then when the gamma stuff
happened that element of his personality
is what the hulk attached and grew from
if that makes sense this was later
expanded upon by writers like peter
david uh and the term multiple
personality disorder was updated to the
new modern parlance of disassociative
identity disorder so any way you like to
think about it at the end of the day
the soul will always be bruce banner
there is no hulk without banner like
hulk works so hard to keep banner alive
because hulk's like dependent on banner
so maybe through some magic i know we
talked about it before you could get two
separate entities together but as it
stands really always inside of hulk or
bruce is the soul of bruce banner
deep bro down this is true that makes
sense i like that this little spirit i
really love how and i really hope that
marvel studios goes into this as well
how the hulk is just this this like
super juiced up aspect of
bruce's just like really messed up
personality like he's he's essentially
just manifested anger he's just yeah
anger made real it's we all have it's
crazy yeah we all have that anger and
that anger inside of all of us i believe
there's anger in all of us does feel
like this uncontrollable monster that
even you know even the best of us as
hard as we try we get too angry
sometimes we say things we don't know
i've never been angry in my life brandon
i mean i only live in massachusetts
where uh
boston drivers are insane i've never
been angry at them and scream at them
and give them the finger once a day not
me
you gotta do what you gotta do on the
road that's not true all bets are off on
the roads guys well um thank you for
that brandon but i got another one for
you ready for this one i'm ready
question number two brandon is it
uncomfortable to ride a broomstick in
the harry potter world and this is from
iajsmith24 on discord thank you aj smith
that's actually a very good question
because i i could never do that because
i feel like i would have just wood
lodged in my cheeks and i that's not
comfortable ah that's going to be taken
out of context i'll take that one out of
the context mt's got that wood between
his legs you know what i'm talking about
between my cheeks
too uncomfortable
um
yeah i mean if you've ever run around
your house with a broom tucked between
your legs pretending you're the captain
of your own quidditch team r.i.p to my
boy cedric diggory they did you dirty
hufflepuff
i think that's what he got hufflepuffs
are not supposed to do courageous
like that we're supposed to eat our
chocolate frogs just sit down you've
probably got already to deduce that
actually sitting on like a flying broom
would suck and be extremely
uncomfortable it just wouldn't work it
wouldn't work and this is obviously like
an old trope of witches that they ride
around on brooms you know
that's all it is but what since when
you've never seen this never heard this
have you ever heard of halloween uh but
you guys aren't wrong you know balancing
on a broomstick as it like zooms through
the sky would pretty much be impossible
there'd be like
there's no way to stay on that it would
be so hard but folks we're just mere
muggles out here okay
thankfully the wizards and witches they
have the use of magic that fixes
everything in their precious happy
little magic universe lucky
it's not fair uh
to make sitting on their broom so much
easier witches and wizards imply a
cushioning charm on their brooms the
charm itself is called moliere uh i
might be pronouncing that incorrectly
molaire moliere uh and in latin it's a
it's it's the verb form of the latin
word that means to soften or make calm
which i believe is just molar molar but
moliere is is the charm that they use uh
the charm is that where teeth are called
molars because they make her
soft maybe like that big sense yeah
though anyways put that in the
dictionary or the encyclopedia that
sounds right to me so this charm was
invented by elliot smithwick in 1820. it
was it was primarily used to fix this
whole broomstick problem that they had
uh and that's mostly what the charm is
used for though we do see hermione use
the charm in deathly hallows part two
where they're in the mine cart and green
guts and it's going off the tracks and
they almost fall to their doom she uses
a little mollier spell so that they land
softly a little like a little cushion of
landing and i guess the spell is also
used
in the cursed child but some people
don't like that piece of text um
that's all i'll say about that uh
so witches and wizards can use the charm
whenever they need like a comfy place to
sit which would be awesome uh it must be
nice to constantly have magic to better
your lives uh leaving us muggles to
painfully sit in our awful office office
chairs day after day after day like
listen witches and wizards just come
help us please stop living in your own
little world we'll be nice
stop calling us struggle muggles and
just help us okay
my ass hurts my ass sitting on this
uncomfortable channel i'll show you how
a toaster works if you just give me a
little bit of magic please seriously so
yeah that cushioning charm it makes like
a nice little invisible magical pillow
that they can sit on uh and so magic
once again saves the day and disregards
the laws of physics isn't it beautiful
but still i think maddai moody had the
right idea with his like recumbent broom
that looks like a motorcycle looks like
a chopper that he can just like lean
back yeah it's got like a little seat on
it and like good little footholds and
like handlebars like that's all the
broom should look like that why not do
that it looks so much better so much
better
so much i would not want to ride a broom
that's the stupidest thing in the world
like why like that's i feel like that
that's what you start off with that's
what the wizarding world started up we
start off with brooms and then we go to
the you know the car the flying cars and
look like we don't have to be i mean
some of those brooms look pretty tight
though with the nice little like
tailored bristlines a little silver
chrome my dish
i could rock a nimbus 2000 like i wonder
how like how much the bristle factors in
oh you gotta have good bristle
top-notch bristle top-notch it's like oh
my god you got this long bristle though
man you're going about to go fast my boy
you bout to go real fast look at these
bristles
empty let's tell the folks at home our
houses because the you know they're
asking you know they're asking yes
what's your house bro oh you know what
it is i'm a slytherin full of full
slytherin through and through and if any
of you got anything bad to say about
slytherin come find me come find me
slytherin's rule everyone else drools
okay
okay so you are you're a mouthful
sympathizer i see yeah
yeah yeah
see me myself i am a proud hufflepuff i
love
hufflepuffs so much
stand up stand up you already know what
it is um yeah i just if we're just a
really chill house we just like to be
nice to everybody and just eat our
chocolate frogs and just chill i respect
that mt every hufflepuff i've ever met
is proud of it they're so proud of it
hey man we just we just love loving
people it's beautiful but anyway it is
now time for my favorite part of the
episode it's time for the box of scraps
a box of scraps
now brandon i've got to ask you what
would be the hulk version of you
um so this is like what part of my
personality if it got gamma irradiated
what it what it would be how it would
manifest itself the hulk version of me
uh i think it you know if i was to get
that that dose of gamma and i absorbed
it it wouldn't be a rage you know i got
a little rage in me but i don't i don't
think that one would take over it would
probably be like i i really like this is
this is this will sound nerdy i love
like cleaning my house an apartment uh i
said house i don't have a house i have
an apartment
but i always loved like doing uh yeah
cleaning up because you get to see the
results of your hard work i love doing
like yard work i don't have a yard i
wish i had a yard so i could just do
yard work uh you know i come from a
family of farmers it's in my blood to be
out there toiling the soil living on the
land so i think like the hulk version of
me would yeah be i would be green but
green with like environmentalism
and living i'd be out there just like
till in the soil
you know ripping up trees uh that they
need to be ripped up you know properly
uh building new forests that would be me
like doing work cleaning up putting
things in their place that that that's
like the jolly green giant yeah like the
jolly green giant doing the dishes uh
doing some yard work that's me okay i
like it i dig it what about you mt i
think for me
i would probably have to be like i would
be a hulk that was triggered by just
like
just laughing because like i laugh at
anything i'm a very easily abused person
so i think it'd be hilarious if i just
turned into like this laffy
like i don't know sort of like this
joker hulk every time i just got and
like i had to try not to laugh or else
like it's like all bets are off and i'm
about to turn into this hulk that's just
like
laughs all the time and like destroys
things while he laughs he's just like a
jolly lapper you make me think i don't
know that creepy like robert zemeckis uh
uh uh christmas carol or whatever and
the one it's the ghost of future
christmas present or whatever who's like
the big
jolly guy who's always full of food and
stuff like that he's just like like
laughing it up like i said
that would be you as the as a hulk right
you just seriously that's just exactly
boisterous smiling creature the one from
the uh the mickey mouse one yeah yeah oh
yeah maybe it's the mickey mouse one i
don't know is that i remember i think
the mickey mouse one had that big they
probably did it too
yeah yeah we're mixing up our christmas
guys creeped me the oh yeah like
mickey
too creepy
but that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank of course off
screen in quotes
producer brandon for joining me this
episode you can follow him at
grindenberric on twitter he's a great
man please follow him there and you can
follow me at mastertainment not as great
as brandon but uh still way better than
me mt how dare you how dare you follow
mt he only he tweets like 500 times a
day follow him please literally 500
times a minute uh it's really bad but
most importantly follow new rockstars
here on youtube and on twitter and when
you do on youtube please hit that
notification bell you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and please hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get cool
shirts like our new shun t-shirt and all
of our you know suicide squads and all
our really dope shirts there because
it's really great way to support the
channel but yeah thank you for watching
and we'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you